a man walks in and talks about the
downfall of his empire he's surrounded
by a bunch of guards with weapons in
their hands he introduces himself as
armanosa the guardian of people the last
of a secret arm created by king of the
julian empire for protecting the earth
and its people we're introduced to the
land of dulcine where it lived special
warriors called arminosa these highly
skilled men used to travel the land in
disguise to help the common people and
fight against the corrupt government
officials as well as bringing justice to
the people of the country they were the
peacemakers but as time passed duchenne
failed in its mission however one
arminosa continued to travel through the
distant desert in scorching heat to
continue the mission but the heat gets
to him and he has no water he falls and
becomes unconscious a boy traveling with
his camel tries to wake him up and give
up water to quench his thirst the boy
warns him about syringes the man eating
desert devils but the man isn't afraid
instead he laughs after hearing about
them the man thanks the boy for saving
his life and the two introduced
themselves the young lad's name is mon
he's out in the desert with a desert bat
and a camel he used to be a veterinarian
but aspires to be an armanosa he's out
here to save his girlfriend chun she's a
kind-hearted woman and a fighter who's
held captive by the tyrant leader lord
beyond munsu the bitter warrior is
disgusted to learn about the boy's
motivation to become an armanosa this
conversation enrages the boy and he
yells at him and asks who does he think
he is
munsu throws an amulet at the boy and
walks away it's a medallion of the three
horses he gives the boy this antique to
repay him for the water munsu comes back
again and asks him to return the
medallion mon tells him he's changed his
plan and he will learn martial arts to
save his girlfriend then from out of
nowhere blood starts trickling from his
chest he's been fatally wounded by the
syringes the scary beasts with tails one
of them attacks munsu but he quickly
takes out his gun and shoots it our
protagonist has two guns and is ready to
bring every sarina down
munsu convinces these ugly beasts to
spare his life and in exchange he hands
them over mont's corpse the beast agree
and begin enjoying their feast wait
there's a catch there's a bomb planted
inside the boy's corpse that blows the
hell out of these creatures and boom
they're all dead we see a headband
flying and landing in front of munsu's
feet and he decides to wear it the boy's
bat now accompanies munsu who thinks
he's responsible for the boy's death and
he decides to take up his mission and
save his girlfriend
at the new leader's fortress a giant guy
is squishing people to death and the
leader is enjoying the sight if one of
the villagers managed to kill the giant
they will be released but the leader
goes against his words and banishes
their family to die in the desert's heat
one of the court men informs the lord
that chun tried to harm her and he
decides to see her the girl is chained
and tied to the wall the lord tells it
that no arminosa is coming for her
rescue and that she must surrender and
start her life with him the lord is
looking for mercenary to protect himself
he's informed that one mercery has come
forward and he was asked to defeat 100
men at the same time as a test and so
the test begins and the mercenary has to
defeat all of the commoners the
mercenary reveals himself and it's munsu
the armanosa who's come to take down the
lord's army and eliminate his empire
munsu pushes the commoners and tells
them he's not here to save them once who
takes off his mask and uses the
medallion to unleash his powers and
summon an army of phantom soldiers to
destroy the lord's army while unleashing
his powers the army also make it clear
that nothing like this will happen for
the villagers again because clearly he's
here to save chun all he does is blow a
whistle and the phantom soldiers
slaughter every man just when one of
them is about to target the lord phantom
soldiers tune comes to his rescue alone
she manages to defeat the entire army of
phantom soldiers now she's in a sword
fight with munsu who's surprised to see
a woman taking him down just like that
munsu plays his final move by
distracting tune and firing shots at her
but she manages to dodge and cut the
bullets in half by using her sword just
when she's about to kill him she notices
munsu is wearing mon's hairband a
flashback takes us into the past where
she gifts the hairband to her boyfriend
and mom tells her that he wants to be at
arminosa and that she can be her sando
his bodyguard and accompany her since
arminosis can't have family
tune breaks down while this is happening
the villagers take down the lord and
kill him tuna visits her boyfriend's
final resting place there she offers to
become munsu's bodyguard the sando and
he accepts the two of them set out to
complete munsu's original mission a lad
from another island comes searching for
munsu the armanosa and asks for help but
he refuses the boy had something in his
hand that makes munsu curious and he
decides to help the boy can't seem to
remember why he came to the armanosa for
help the three of them set on a boat to
travel to the lads island once they've
reached the island he asks sando to hide
herself the boy whose name is joon is
captured by the men on the island and is
put to sleep by the castle's only
physician master yuite june's parents
have recently been killed and an
emotionally unstable lad keeps bothering
others to ask for help the rulers
apologize to the trouble and request
monsoo to stay in the island for a few
days as compensation he accepts the
offer readily while showing him the
island one of the men tells munso that
pirates are on the loose and the
security of the people is a threat munsu
decides to take a stroll at night and
sees doom walking by with his sister
june tells him the doc is a miracle
worker he has the power to bring people
from the dead back to life and that he
is his apprentice muntu has nothing but
the brutal truth to say to the land and
so he does he tells him there's no such
thing as a miracle and everything he
believes in is a fraud the next morning
mutsu heads to the forest to search the
leaves he found in june's hand when he
first met him he's able to find the
matching leaves when he pulls out the
leaves the plant that looks like a body
of a woman screams the physician pops up
and tells him more about this strange
plant medicinal herb called mandrake it
screams like a vengeful spirit when it's
pulled from the ground according to
legend if an ordinary man attempts its
harvest he will die muntsu expresses
that among his old acquaintances was a
man with the powers that the doctor has
but he doesn't quite look like him munsu
asks the doctor come clean and the
doctor asks the same and walks away from
the scene he comes searching for june
and asks him to try to dig into his
memory and remember why he came looking
for him he asks if it was something
about the island that made him run away
and forces the boy to speak the truth
about the miracles everyone had been
talking about across the island he asked
the boy to give it a thought and come to
him when he's ready mutsu was attacked
by a strange lady at night and sando
comes to his rescue he yells at sando
for not following his orders and staying
hidden munso throws the hairband and
asks her to leave him alone since he's
not a replacement for her boyfriend
sando apologizes and promises not to
disobey his orders again
at night while lying in his bed munsu
remembers that june told him the doctor
can bring the dead back to life then we
see a memory from the past the same
forest appears in front of the screen
and the woman-like trees are there
alongside a vampire-like creature jun is
shocked to witness that scared from what
he saw he runs away it was a bad dream
june rushes to see munsu but he's not in
his room he's being invited by the lord
to accompany him for breakfast the doc
is there too munso says it's strange
there are no animals on the island the
doctor explains that an epidemic struck
a few years back affecting both humans
and animals since yui day was the only
doctor he could only save the humans
munsu shares a similar story june
arrives at the scene yelling he
remembers everything yui day is a devil
with wings munso shoots everyone at the
table except the doctor the strange
woman comes jumping from the above and
slashes both muntsu and june to death
the two turn into pieces of papers the
woman's name is marie and she looks like
yuuite's bodyguard the mandrake forest
has caught fire jun munsu and sando are
standing there watching the trees burn
then we revisit the scene where june
rushes to munsu's apartment muntsu asks
him to come with him if he wants to
learn the truth they're at the forest
munsu gives one of his guns to the boy
and ordesando to stay there and make
sure the forest burns completely
munsu and jun walk together an old man
asks joon if something's on fire muntu
asks the man if he's dead he says that
yuite has brought him to life several
times munsu shoots him to death again
and everyone else around
june's sister asks what's happening and
munsu points the gun at her too jun begs
him not to shoot her munsu agrees but
asks june to shoot her instead because
it's the only way he'll learn the truth
about the island the boy looks deeper
and remembers when he came back to this
island from catching fish everyone was
dead dr yuite comes to him and gives him
a needle treated with mandrake the boy
realizes that everyone is dead including
his sister and so he shoots her the
doctor conjured those who died in the
epidemic and made them think they were
resurrected the doctor arrives and tells
that he didn't do this for his own glory
he instead wanted to use his powers to
save those who had fallen into despair
he wanted to ease the boy's pain june
tells him that even when every one of
his wishes was fulfilled when the doctor
arrived to the island he always had
doubts the doctor becomes angry and
summons the spirits of the dead to make
him taste the agony of the reality
the doctor says he could have turned
this place into a paradise but instead
he decided to turn against him and
everyone he loved hence rising his wrath
munsu uses his medallion to unleash the
phantom soldiers and orders them to take
these spirits and deliver them to
purgatory and decides to take on the
dock all by himself marie and sando face
each other and the battle begins the two
give each other a tough sword fight
meanwhile the doctor tells munsu about
mandrake needle that will make him live
for eternity but he turns down the offer
munsu decides to take the doctor down
with his only one weapon meanwhile sando
manages to defeat marie with her sword
skills the doctor throws thunder at
munsu who ends up dropping his weapon he
grabs him by the neck and asks him why
he provoked him despite knowing he's
powerful mutsu responds by saying he
never played by the rules he takes out
his hidden gun and shoots the doctor in
the head but the dock is still alive
fortunately sando arrives at the spot
and beheads the doctor when the dog
started to regenerate munsu steps on his
head and takes out another hidden weapon
to shoot him but shoots his body instead
because if the doctor doesn't have a
body he wouldn't be able to return
before dying the doc asks him who was
the man munsumas took him for it was
ajit day he's the reason munsu refuses
to die he wishes to track him down and
kill him but that's for another story
joon realizes that he didn't survive the
epidemic either he takes out the gun
ones who gave him happily returning to
heaven
rest in peace june come so this is it
for today's video if you liked the video
give it a huge thumbs up and subscribe
to the channel for more videos farewell
till next time